yeah it was when we came in saying hi
here we are yeah we're gonna win bye
yeah exactly is the presentation moment
hello this
i'm the is i'm thomas and i'm the guitar
player i'm damian the vocalist i'm
victor and i'm the bass player today
with gq we're gonna tell you all about
our style history
[Music]
yeah it was incredible first gig in the
us uh the boulder battle room one of the
wildest gigs we ever played to be honest
it was so nice because there were no
fires from the audience to us because it
was a very small venue we really felt
the energy from from the people and we
could stage dive many times yeah exactly
it's crazy to go like in all the
different cities and see if there's so
many people there for you that know all
of your songs and it's great we always
try to coordinate our outfits and uh
that's it yeah yeah we just have fun
with it
experiment and have fun mix it all up
i really love the face of ethan
it was the the jimmy fallon
late night show our first tv show here
in the us and we were dressed amazing
gucci yeah we were wearing gucci yeah it
was amazing
fun but also tiring because we shot
only during the night so we just like we
didn't slept for three days and every
time that we were done with the shooting
we were all covered in blood so when we
we got back home it was a bit weird like
to meet people on the streets
covered in blood but it was very fun for
my outfit the the reference was uh was
meteors i wanted to look like a
paparazzi shoot pop star like uh lindsay
lohan with the iconic t-shirts and
britney and
i wanted to be like that
we're missing one yeah yeah yeah i
wasn't there because yeah where are you
doing your
four hours of training to get to the
expo we were like playing as buskers
nice line marketing it was in rome and
it feels like ages ago yeah thomas was
already doing his dance yeah
iconic dance yeah yeah we were playing i
can definitely say la der nier dance by
india yeah remember
[Music]
this is the final of uh the san remo
festival when we won yeah
as you can see from the beautiful golden
tree with the lion standing
who was it
no no i steal a victoria every time we
get a trophy we have to fight to get to
to hold it so
we're sharing it now now
now we have someone stole it he came at
my place while i wasn't there and took
it
we looked like uh being escaped
okay yeah the night was magic
terrific yeah
it's your vision when i was like uh
seven feet tall
yeah cheating cheating with my high
heels and we won the eurovision uh it
was when we won
was it when we won no my my ears are
still done so we hadn't won yet yeah it
was when we came in saying hi here we
are yeah we're gonna win bye yeah
exactly that is the presentation moment
it was very tight yeah but it was comfy
yours maybe mine wasn't
bowie was the reference but that's it
this is just me uh dressed like a sexy
nurse no no the nurse uh
calls cool like yeah madonna inspo
they were the
yeah it was
normal jack sparrow stuff and uh
i don't know how the [ __ ] am i dressed
but
but
it felt cool i just want to wear it
this is mean girls in
an iconic dust that we we
saw in sweden in the uh on the
background at the back of lotte
palinsburg yeah it was like an amusement
park yeah it was uh basically the
merchandise of the place yeah exactly
it's cool and scary at the same time
yeah yeah it's like happy tree friends
it's everywhere it's everywhere boobs
i think like it's very important for
everyone to like feel free to be
theirselves like but with your body but
also with your like gender and sexuality
and just with who you are in general and
like nowadays i think there's like so
much discrimination and the society
tries to put so many limits on you and
trying to tell you like who you should
be or how you should dress and also like
on the
woman's body there's always like much
sex sexualizing and i think like it's
a very like bad thing of course and
everyone should be free just to be
themselves and look how they feel
comfortable so that's why i'm forced to
cover my nipples
the most important thing also to
be free to discover who you are is to be
surrounded by people who are open and
free and won't judge you but of course a
lot of people just i don't know like
mistook me
as a
feminine like i don't like thing just
because of my hair which is a wrong
thing of course
so
for me
they are also i don't know concept of
freedom all natural
iconic on
you watch it every day
no no every day like it wouldn't be a
little bad
and i think like every two or three
years
years
thirty
years zoe
dirty
iconic person absolutely
yeah it's a royal family
yeah those two you're seeing out
like the
smart part of the equipment
the royal part of the
park and very uncomfortable
for me it was
like oh my god
my leg was like oh shaking
and the photographer which like is one
of our biggest friends he was like hold
it back please hold it i can't anymore
it was very fun because when i remember
when we were wearing those outfits and
damiana had like black lipstick and
massive like smoky eyes and then we were
like playing a soft ballad in italian
and it was very fun
it was like marley manson singing
romantic music it was very fun yeah but
it was cool the the opposite you know
yeah it was very cool just exactly
my favorite one is the one in the video
because i really feel like uh
early 2000's pop star for me the
performance in states in new york
because it's really you know elegant
during the performance of the
elegant yeah i was half naked so i'm not
developing because it looks like jimmy
page yeah exactly and also a romantic
wave you know i love the one from the
aerovision this one was yeah awesome and
for me the jimmy fallon one because i
wear like plug with the belt which is a
harness altogether and an old harness so
that's why
thanks for watching our style history on
gq wow
[Music]